he's from New York he is Patricia Powell
she is the president and CEO of the
Powell Financial Group good morning
thank you very much for being with us
good morning thanks for having me the
Sunday section of the New York Times
pressing all the buttons for a panic
attack the word commonly used in this
article fear based on what happened last
week the Dow Thursday and then the news
late Friday after the markets closed
with s P so what's your advice well
first of all I think the don't panic is
always a good advice no matter what's
going on
panic never leads you to a really good
decision and this and the reason I think
people are panicking or are very
concerned is the memory of 2008 is so
very very recent and in 2008 we came
perilously close to economic collapse
what's going on now is not by the
slightest measure anywhere near what
happened in 2008 it's ugly
the markets have been brutal for two
weeks not just last week but for two
weeks and it's worldwide but I think
don't panic is really the best advice
how much influence does Standard &
Poor's have on the markets and this
credit rating which was downgraded while
Fitch and Moody's kept it at the
triple-a sterling rating yeah I think
they are influential and I think they
knew that which is why it was really
clear that when they did the downgrading
they did it after the markets closed on
Friday and they gave us the whole
weekend to try to digest it I know there
was some political work going on behind
the scenes for the administration going
back and forth with them but I think it
was very clear that they're concerned
what the impact this is going to have on
the markets we heard many refer to the
Lost Decade with regard to Japan and now
some wondering if the u.s. is facing a
Lost Decade
economically is that a fair comparison
or a fair analysis I think the concept
of a Lost Decade is fair I think the
reasons are very different and I think
we already went through a Lost Decade if
you look at the last 10 years what this
economy went through between the dot-com
bubble bursting and the economic fallout
of that 9/11 the economic fallout of
that the massive fraud of Enron
and many other companies and the
economic fallout of that and then of
course the economic crisis of 2008 if
you look at the Standard & Poor's
numbers you're going to find that if
you'd been an investor in the 500 for
the last ten years you had just
marginally a very small gain over a
ten-year period so I think we could
argue that investors have had a Lost
Decade has had a tremendous impact on
pensions on 401ks
every aspect of society and you talk to
some people who just want to break even
with some of their investments in many
which have lost a lot of money you hear
the sentiment you can't even get ahead
during the last ten years it's been very
difficult to get ahead and stay ahead
and you've certainly taken a lot of
knocks but the answer for the last ten
years it was and the answer for the next
ten years is probably the same is you
have to have diversity you can't just do
a no-brainer kind of investment approach
where I'll put all my money in an S&P
index fund and I it will be fine in the
long run I think people have to have to
do a much better job of allocating a lot
of work has been done on passive
investing and I think it's led people to
some pretty bad results so what's your
advice as individuals try to figure out
how best to manage their personal
finances at a time when the savings rate
is at a historic low renewed concerns
about investing in the stock market gold
prices are high there's really no return
on any savings account so what can you
do well it's it's tough and I think the
first thing you have to do is
differentiate between your short-term
money and your long-term money your
short-term money should not be invested
it's a classic mistake that people make
over and over again I have another
tuition payment due in January and I've
got in the stock market and then the
stock market starts to fall apart and
the next thing you know I'm panicked
because I need that money in January
that kind of money belongs in a cash
reserve safe secure I like banks I like
an FDIC guarantee on that kind of on
that kind of money but for your
long-term money I think you do have to
go beyond that and
look at you've got to take care of your
care of yourself if you are ever going
to retire you need to participate in
things like a 401k that maybe your
employer sponsors if your employer
doesn't sponsor something like that then
you have to participate in an IRA you
are at some point not going to want to
work and doing nothing now is not going
to be personally helpful to you so let's
put out a scenario that you are an
individual that makes $75,000 a year how
much should you be saving how much
should be put into a retirement fund and
typically if you retire at 65 or 68 how
much do you need to retire for 20 years
okay I'm tough a little bit tough the
way you way you laid it out so I'm going
to sort of skirt around it a bit the
$75,000 person I don't know you know one
income family to income family there's
lots of factors so the younger you are
the I think the easier it is for you to
get started but most people wait and the
sooner you get started the better off
you the better off you are you take a
kid just getting out of college start
immediately on your first job start
putting money away immediately you'll
never feel it I would suggest to you
that somebody who put 10% of their money
away over their entire career would
never have a problem in retirement now
that's that's pretty strong statement
and it's not that hard if you start out
at night and I know most young college
graduates are not starting out at 75,000
they might start out at 40 I will
suggest to you that a $40,000 standard
of living is substantively the same as a
$36,000 standard of living but the
outcome of that 10% savings plan is
light years away from somebody who
spends everything they make I guest is
Patricia policies joining us from New
York what is the power Financial Group
and who do you advise we are a small
business a small advisor we advise
individuals and trusts and we manage
money we do for both financial planning
and money money management and we manage
about 140 million dollars right now
maybe a little less after after this
week but we we manage people for the
long term and one of the things we
always say to our clients is I don't
want your short-term money here I don't
want your money that is slated for a
temporary savings or and expended a
short-term expenditure I only want your
long-term long-term money and we're
active money managers and by that I mean
we move we don't stay with one strategy
forever market conditions change and
individual conditions change so we move
with them and the book that you
co-authored creating prosperity how do
you do that um well one of the things
you do is you you have to start with
yourself you have to look mostly to
yourself and you start with your own
budget if every dollar you have in your
budget is being spent then you will
never get ahead and many Americans for
every dollar they make they're spending
a dollar ten cents and that is just a
prescription for disaster so you always
have to start with your own budget but
once you start start there you now start
carving out some money that will be for
your long-term savings and your
long-term investments when you some of
the best things we have available to us
are things like 401ks Roth IRAs you
carve out a portion you put it into the
into these vehicles if you're lucky your
employer may match something a
twelve-year 401k so you put a dollar in
and maybe your employer is matching
fifty cents that's a pretty nice return
on your on your money and it gives you
again a boost towards your retirement
you have to actually pay attention to
these one classic mistake a lot of
people make is they take all of their
money and they put it in company stock
they love the company they work for
imagine today if you work for Apple
Computer how tempting it would be to put
all of your 401k into a company stock
and the word that I always say to people
when we talk about this is Enron there
was a time when Enron looked just like
Apple like there was no top note no tech
no top to there their market price now
that I'm not trying to imply that Apple
is going to be it
is doing anything wrong I'm just saying
that when you put money into company
stock you can have a disastrous effect
so I think number one make sure you have
a diversified portfolio
if you've rode through the last two
weeks the markets down more than ten
percent in the last two weeks it's down
seven percent in the last week alone but
if you throw through this suppose your
401k you had 40 percent of your 401k
invested in the stock market well ten
percent of 40 percent means you had a
four percent decline on that money
perhaps your bonds actually went up a
little not very much this week and
perhaps you even have a little gold in
the portfolio that helps mitigate some
of the damage and it helps get you
through these tough times
our guest is Patricia Powell you can
join the conversation by giving us a
call 2:02 is the area code here in
Washington DC six to four 1115 are
aligned for Republicans into zero to six
to four eleven eleven for Democrats we
have a line for independence and if
you're watching outside the United
States on satellite or on the web two
zero two seven three seven two five
seven nine from our Twitter page Scott
has this point would you rather I give
you fifty thousand dollars in gold or
50k in cash that's a very interesting
and tough question and being a money
manager I would never do all of either
but I certainly am a big fan of cash and
I'm a small fan of gold at over $1600 an
ounce I was a bigger fan when it was
under a thousand dollars an ounce dan is
joining us from Waterbury Connecticut
Republican line with patricia powell
good morning Dan good morning things
seems to be everything I'm gonna call I
see I had a call a question for the
earlier caller but I guess it means she
can feel this one too how can we trust
our stock market when they gave triple-a
ratings to jump pretty much garbage
mortgage that subprime mortgages how can
you really trust the stock market I mean
you know people live paycheck to
paycheck you know how can you really you
know 401k you know when the economy
less than everybody had this is triple-a
triple-a everything with seeing a
triple-a but it was just literally
garbage so how can you really trust this
back Marquis thanks Dan and I think
you're referring to SMPS rating some of
those earlier derivatives patricia
powell can you respond well i don't
think you can trust the stock market so
i when you make an investment in the
stock market you are at risk and you
have to know that going in you can't say
i'll put it in everything will be okay
but the reason that most of us would
advise people to have some of their
money into into the stock market is that
stocks have weathered historically just
about every crisis you can imagine they
have recovered from the crash of 29 from
the great depression from world war two
from the Korean War from the Cuban
Missile Crisis from the Vietnam War the
Cold War they've even they be covered
from 9/11 so if you look at this and
you'd say there is a really strong
history of recovery but that's a large
basket of stocks not any individual
stocks not all companies recover some go
out of some go out of business so I'm
not a fan of trusting anyone
I'm a fan though of looking carefully at
your portfolio making calculated risks
and I tend to like to buy when things
are cheaper not when they're more
expensive and I tend to raise cash when
things get get expensive so I'm not
asking and I don't think people should
look to the stock market or corporate
America and say I trust you that's not
what that's not what is going to work
for you
I guess Patricia Powell who earned her
MBA at Seton Hall University with a
market down so significantly is it a
good time to invest a good time to buy
well it's always a good time to invest
I'm not sure it's a good time to buy I'm
not expecting on Monday to go in and be
buying for a lot of my my clients we
don't really know how it's going to
going to go we only have one mark one
group of markets that's open since the
downgrade and that was the Middle East
and I'm not sure that Dubai is a really
good indicator what will happen on an
hour
it's we'll have to see how Asia goes and
then we'll have to see how Europe opens
but now I'm sort of bracing that we
might get a little bit more of the same
I think it might be a very difficult
beginning and it might be difficult week
but I'm not really that concerned that
this is not going to cause the world to
come come apart it's not good it's
serious but but by when you look at our
economy we are still growing we are not
in recession yet I heard you mention on
in in the last segment that Larry
Summers says that the probability of
recession he would put at one point one
out of three I would agree with them now
that would mean that there's two out of
three shot that that we don't go into
into recession and that that's good our
next call is Brian joining us from
Wallingford Connecticut good morning
Democrats line hi Patricia Bryan from
Wallingford Connecticut just what I need
two questions the first is a quick one
yes or no if you who if you put a
significant culprit from Wall Street
behind bars would things turn around and
they might think twice about putting the
world economy in jeopardy next time
around I think if you find that someone
has done something illegal then you take
the actions that are necessary and you
we have a legal process by which we we
can put people from corporate America in
in jail it's difficult you can see even
in the Enron process there was only
there's only been a couple of people who
have actually gone to jail over over
that so but I think you have to look at
was anything that happened was it
illegal and if it was then you have to
take action against it and if you did
that which amend a tremendous signal
white-collar workers CEOs don't like
going to jail another sentiment from one
of our viewers saying that the stock
market is quote legalized gambling your
reaction i I don't agree with that
statement but it certainly is legalized
risk-taking when you put a dollar into
and
for the investment you have to know that
it can decline and sometimes the
declines are fast and furious but it's
also how we built this country it's also
how we employ the tens of millions of
people going to work every every day and
it's through this idea of capitalism I
know your viewers identify themselves as
Republican Democrat or independent and I
have identified myself as a capitalist I
it's an economic philosophy that I think
has worked for this country it's built a
juggernaut of an economy and we're
really we've had some struggles and I
think we're we might be just throwing
out the baby with the bathwater as we
look for other alternatives wide open
Powell over the last really 20 years
we've seen such wild swings the market
up 400 points down 5 or 600 is it an
unusual pattern or is it a sign of the
times
well the 2008 wild swings were really a
result of I think the markets and the
people investing in the markets
disseminating a great deal of very bad
information and I think I said it
earlier that in 2008 we came perilously
close to economic collapse and that the
the the the wild days that we had in the
market were actually rational the when
they did fail to pass tarp in the fall
of 2008 there was a 777 points swing
downward in the Dow in just that one day
and that was not a political statement
that was fear that we we had what we
were dealing with was incredibly serious
today the the swings that we have going
into this weekend before we hit the SP
change in rating I would have said that
we were going through a normal
correction Corrections cap and after
markets go up for a while we were down a
little bit more than 10%
I wasn't excessively concerned with the
downgrade over the weekend I'm a little
bit more concerned than when I started
at the weekend why so
because I think it's serious I think
that they're putting us on notice that
we have some structural issues and I
think it actually was rather courageous
of SP to step forward and not cave to
political pressure and keep the rating
at a triple triple-a clearly the the
easy thing would have been to just find
a reason and say well please don't don't
don't do anything make anything worse
but instead they actually said you
didn't lower the deficit by the four
trillion dollars that we said would be
necessary to create to maintain this
rating and so they were through it I
think that was a courageous statement on
their part and I there's going to be
fallout for them as a company the
downgrade the downgrade quote reflects
our opinion SP s opinion that the fiscal
consolidation plan that Congress and the
administration recently agreed to fall
short of what would be necessary to
stabilize the government's medium-term
debt dynamics Scott has this point from
our Twitter page who believes Americans
will pay back the fourteen and a half
trillion dollars and of course it's that
figure and the debt agreement that
stretched out over the past month with
the political give-and-take that led to
the decision by S&P on Friday I I don't
think it's the fourteen point three
trillion dollars I think it's the
expected expansion of the fourteen point
three trillion dollars if you look at
2010 we spent approximately 412 413
billion dollars in interest if you look
at the first ten months of fiscal 2011
we spent almost the same amount we still
have two months to go the debt it is the
expansion of debt and the fear that it
would when interest rates rise not if
interest rates rise but when they rise
that we could get a huge explosion of
debt servicing that would make things
truly unmanageable John is joining us
from LA Crescent Minnesota good morning
hi good morning Patricia how are you
today good morning John I'm fine good I
recently retired oh my mistake
is in
a money market with Vanguard and I'm
thinking about looking at but maybe a
third of it to do a conservative
investment with maybe a five-year span
on it what would you suggest okay thank
you I'm sorry she gave me your age I did
quite catch it did you give me your age
35 Wow 65 okay what you have to look at
is how long you are really going to be
retired and how long you're going to
need this money and when you're going to
need income from this from this money
what I usually would say to somebody and
you're in your position you have to look
at this as at least 20-year money it
might be 25 or 30 year money because you
could be here at 90 or 95 not all of us
will make it that far but some of us
will and those who do don't want to run
out of money so this has to be long-term
money so the pace of spending out of
this account is going to be incredibly
important you some of this money should
be segregated and said I know that this
money has to be here 10 15 to 20 years
out and that's the money that you should
look at as investing for a
middle-of-the-road
investor in in my office for for the
last year or so we've been very light on
equities but not at zero we've been
running at about 30 to 40 percent of the
portfolio being in equities we've also
had positions in bonds we've also had
positions in gold and commodities and I
don't see that this would be
substantively different on surface for
somebody like like you but if you're
taking large chunks of money out of this
account to maintain your standard of
living then I would say anything that is
above four percent you have to think and
say that money is not investment money
that's that money belongs in very very
safe investments and in all honesty if
you're in a money market fund and you
compare it maybe to bank CD's you might
actually do a little better in bank CD's
right now you might have to go back and
forth if you work for a company that
does not provide a 401 K but you want to
make a retirement investment
what advice do you give consumers and
what's the difference between a 401k and
a Roth IRA okay a 401k is actually an
expansion of a profit sharing plan the
401k refers to a provision in the tax
code so when you're talking about before
1 K you're talking about the tax code it
allows your viewers or employees to
contribute in pre-tax dollars into a
retirement plan that is managed through
their employer it's usually a separate a
separate trust typically you can put
quite a bit of money for most viewers it
would be a lot of money you can put 16
thousand five hundred dollars into a 401
K out of your out of your own money if
you're over 50 you can put another
$5,500 into that that get you into the
neighborhood of $22,000 and if your
employer matches that it's often they'll
match maybe the first five or six
percent often at fifty percent but you
put another three percent on top of that
you can have 25 percent of your gross
income going into one of these one of
these retirement plans so so it's a it's
a really good thing now that Congress
has not elected to be as generous to
people who have to do it themselves and
I will never understand this now if you
have to do it yourself
you can do a Roth IRA but a Roth IRA is
a an IRA that is in after-tax dollars
not before tax dollars so you get no
immediate tax benefit but Beauty though
of a Roth IRA is that if you meet the
standards your IRA is you've had the
money in the IRA for at least five years
and you're over fifty nine and a half
when you withdraw the money you can take
any and all the money out without
incurring any federal income taxes so
the 401 K just defers the Roth IRA turns
it into a tax-free vehicle and that can
be incredibly powerful in retirement
your restrictions are much lower though
you can only put five thousand dollars
into a Roth IRA there are income
restrictions on that depending upon
whether your what your filing status
status is whether you're filing single
whether you're filing as a married
couple and if you breach certain levels
you can't do a Roth IRA so it's rather
restrictive and you do get the not
to put an extra thousand in for those of
us over fifty Anna's join es Echo Valley
Tennessee Republican line with Patricia
Powell giving you financial advice in
these uncertain economic times good
morning and also the benefit of a Roth
they can't force you to take the money
out when you don't want to because they
have to do the minimum deduction and
that hit me when the market was down at
the very lowest but the business of
America is business and we have a man
new who hates capitalism in the White
House until we get him out of there
people are not going to be investing and
you look at the EPA where he is given a
bunch of money she Lisa Jackson has her
foot on the neck of the entrepreneur and
she took money from the EPA to have rap
musicians write a song indoctrinate
young school children against the
business house people going to have any
faith in this stock market when we have
a president like that in the White House
and we need to get him out of there and
Steve there you stop letting Democrats
like Elliot from New York
Carlino most public in line and the
independent line you're gonna lose all
credibility with anybody appreciate the
call in we do try our best it's not a
perfect system but thank you for your
call in comment Patricia Powell did you
want to respond it's kind of a hard
common thing for me to respond to
because it requires more political
background than what I would represent
that I that I have you know we go
through different kinds of philosophies
and I think in addition to the to the
political wrangling that's going on in
Washington there really is a huge
economic argument that is going on and
there are two very different schools of
economic thought that are that are
slugging it out and you have the
Keynesian that really took dominance in
the Great Depression and then you have
those who believe more in free markets
that was perhaps I think that thing led
but perhaps the most prominent member is
is Milton Friedman who wrote extensively
on the value of capitalism
to an interview in free markets and I
think what you see in Washington is a
tremendous argument over witches go
which is the way for us to go as a
society and I don't think it's clear
which one is going to take dominance I
think the Cain teens took dominance
during the crisis of 2000 and 2008 and
it's very hard to argue counterfactuals
as to what would have happened if so I
think you have to you have to let it
play out I'm a little more optimistic
than you are I do think they've made a
terribly hard on entrepreneurs they've
made it terribly hard on those who
create create jobs but entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs are very optimistic and I
sort of come from that school and say
that you know it is always dawn in
America there's always some guy who's in
a garage somewhere trying to figure out
how to be the next Yahoo the next Apple
Computer I'm going to create the next
50,000 50,000 jobs so I I do think it's
a struggle but I I'm not pessimistic
about it AC from Sherman Oaks saying
everyone seems to have forgotten the
small saver most savings accounts are
paying less than 1% interest how can we
grow our money if we're not willing to
whisk it risk it in the market you can't
you cannot grow your money if you're not
willing to risk it what you do when you
do a savings account is you protect your
money and you have to decide what's
important to you if what is important is
to protect that money and have the
security that under no circumstances
that will I have a problem and it will
go down if the bank fails I have a layer
of insulation and FDIC insurance if
that's what's important to you then you
are absolutely in the right place and
you can't eat your heart out about
growth if what you are is a safe saver D
joining us from st. Louis Missouri with
Patricia Powell in New York good morning
to you hi Patricia hi good morning D I
have comments throughout this this show
they have been talking about
population increasing spending to to
increase or improve the economy at the
same time we're talking about the fact
that the average household is spending
anywhere between 138 to 110 percent of
their income and I would say that's just
to get by we want to start talking about
the amount of salary discrepancies
between what given the average household
we're living off credit we're not saving
because we're trying to get by on you
know what literally being divided
between salaries and companies trying to
make their stocks look better and more
and more attractive to do investors so
you know bonuses for CEOs and I just
don't think that that I mean I
appreciate the idea of saving and I I
agree with it but when you look at the
the conflict in the messages being sent
to the American consumer and the
American employee and I just I think
that I know you value capitalism but I
think it's being manipulated to this
top-heavy structure where investors and
getting everything and we're just being
asked to spend more to make them richer
we'll get a response thank you D from
st. Louis
patricia powell and what i'm going to
say is going to sound harsh and i'm
hoping that she will not take it that it
may not necessarily be a personal
response to to her we do overspend in
this country and we have to stop it now
that sounds really easy and and and
almost Cavalier and I apologize for any
hurt feelings that that might come as a
result of this but we have to we have to
gain control of ourselves now there are
people that have hit a particularly
difficult patch
they have lost their job their
unemployment benefits are running out
and so for the moment I'm going to put
those people on the side and really try
to dress more those of us who have a job
we need to live within within our means
and what has happened to us in this
consumer society is we have become
addicted to debt it has been and we've
been enabled to do things with almost
unlimited credit and what we have to do
is say no to ourselves and what I tell
my clients are the adult children of my
clients is the first thing you have to
do is go on a cash basis you have to get
the credit cards out of your wallet and
they're shocked and horrified it and and
what will happen in the short run is
your standard of living will decline
when you do this if you're if you're not
going into Starbucks and charging it on
the credit card and you look in your
wallet and you don't have the four bucks
guess what you're not buying the four
dollar cup of coffee
you've got to maybe make your own coffee
you've got to refill your water bottle
with tap water you've got to take your
kids to the free public library if
you're having trouble making your rent
you have to think about maybe I'm taking
a roommate
if you're having trouble meeting your
mortgage maybe you have to think about
can I home share all of these are things
that are not in the norm of how people
think about their standard of living I
could never I hear I could never live
like that and sometimes the outcome of
not making those cutbacks is you don't
have a home anymore you know you're
you're and I've literally said to
someone you have to give up your
personal trainer and your masseuse who's
coming to the house every Saturday and
the response was I can't do that and I
say well where will they go when you're
living in your car and it may so they
sound really harsh and I know that but
we have to actually gain control of
ourselves it leads us nowhere good to
work work on to go down this road we
really have to spend some time on money
management and we have to do it as a
family and the kids have to be brought
and you know the kids are not a
financial asset their age
men distrain on our finances because
most children have two phrases I need
and I want and we as parents we just
want to give them everything because we
love them so much but we also have we
have to say learn to say no to our
children we have to learn to say no to
ourselves harsh but true one of our
viewers has this comment what I'll miss
my reward points will go to Eddie
joining us from Annapolis on our
independent in Annapolis Maryland good
morning and independent line well
basically I live the lifestyle you're
talking about life saved my money and I
put it in Roth's and I put it in IRAs
and the long came mr. Bush into office
while I was down the Caribbean sailing
and he wiped out all of my gains all I
had left was a principle how do we
protect ourselves from these idiot
politicians playing games with our money
and giving it to the people quite
frankly don't produce anything other
than shuffling money around and throwing
money away into their and into their own
pocket Thank You Eddie I don't know that
you can protect yourself from
politicians mcgann you see the
tremendous debate that's going on in
Washington and the and I believe in in
many cases heartfelt beliefs that are
opposite ends of the spectrum as to what
government should do I tend to come more
from the school that government should
do a little bit less and we should do a
little bit more but until that is
resolved I I think you're always going
to feel that the government is going to
take and I think part of the debate that
you hear is well will will tax rich
people and at the end of the day that's
probably going to happen but we can't
raise enough revenue to cover the kinds
of deficits that we're running by just
taxing rich people and so what you have
to do is you have to start looking to
bring down levels and let me just use a
couple of examples of where governments
have done this in 1986 there was a
tremendous
date between Ronald Reagan and the
Democrats in in the in Washington about
raising taxes and eventually Ronald
Reagan craved it caved in and he did he
did signed to sign a bill for raising
taxes they decided that they were going
to tax those rich Social Security
recipients and they were all talking
about millionaires when the debate
started when the law was finally signed
what we decided was a rich Social
Security recipient was a married couple
making forty four thousand dollars a
year and as an individual filing singly
who was making thirty four thousand
dollars a year and those are still the
levels at which your tax rates change on
Social Security recently we've changed
how we charge seniors premiums on
Medicare it used to be every senior who
put into the system and went into
Medicare paid the exact same premium and
we decided that that was unfair and so
now for a single Medicare participant
you will start paying more if you have
income of over eighty-five thousand for
a married couple it's over one hundred
seventy thousand and there are all these
additional thresholds so when they start
looking for places it's very hard to
hold the line if what you're truly
trying to do is raise revenue and the
the thing that we have to be so cautious
about is when we raise taxes is if we
eat our seeds and that's in the parlance
of farm if we eat our seeds we can make
it harder and harder for the economy to
grow through and that's part of the
answer we have to grow this economy
Keith is joining us from Palm Bay
Florida Republican line welcome to
conversation good morning to you with
patricia powell join us
good morning Peter being here Social
Security was a noble program started off
to protect widows that were more than
likely gonna die before they collected
and it has morphed into a pyramid scheme
which the baby boomers blew up because
the generation after the baby boomers
wasn't bigger and if your group was
running it you would be probably
arrested for running that a pyramid
and I don't believe 55 or under is even
going to collect from that it this also
proves that our education system in the
last 30 years has turned more liberal
arts than academia because graduates if
they even do graduate don't even know
the difference between a fixed mortgage
and an adjustable mortgage but they know
why Sallie has two moms and the last
thing is is it the biggest fall I was
going to be towards state pension plans
with the SPL rating at the other to go
don't these pension plans of the state
pension plans have to be a triple rate a
rating and we've just been living in
fear and insecurity since 9/11 and
historical facts aren't meeting up
because of the bad decisions we have
been making thanks for the call Keith
which goes back to your earlier point
patricia powell
about the losses over the last 10 to 11
years since September 11th
they've been extraordinary on the Qualla
had so many points it's almost
impossible to go and address just all of
them I'm actually going to start with
this first point because I think it's
really near and dear to my heart the
Social Security system has some very
serious systemic problems with it and
the the major problem is baby boomers
those are people born between 1946 and
1964 and I'm one and I'm one of them
the oldest baby boomer turned 65 in the
year 2011 and entered the Medicare
system the oldest baby boomer on January
1 will enter what will turn the full
retirement age for Social Security and
it's not that we those first baby
boomers are going to bankrupt the system
it's that there's 78 million of us baby
boomers who not only contributed to the
system but really contributed the
maximum to the system and really have
been funding all of what has gone on
with the expansion of benefits and they
feel just as entitled as a 70 year old
senior who's in the system in the system
today it is absolutely unsustainable not
only in my opinion but in the opinion
the chief actuary from the Social
Security system to maintain the system
as it currently exists we have to do
something if we do nothing we run
tremendous risks of seeing the kinds of
things that went on in Europe and Greece
turn here if we get a spike in interest
rates lately the 412 3412 413 billion
dollar number that I used earlier as far
as our deficit spending rather our
interest requirement in 2010 is a very
small number that could actually explode
by our interest rates just going up by
three percentage points when Spain and
Ireland had their first downgrade their
10-year bonds we had a small adjustment
I believe for Spain it was 0.2
percentage points upward and for Ireland
it was zero point four percentage points
upward
however the downgrades continued and
when the downgrades continued Spain was
forced to pay troopers say two full
percentage points higher on their debt
and Ireland was forced to pay 4.5
percentage points higher
that would actually more than double the
cost of our interest in this country if
we were forced into the same into the
same situation so what we're talking
about and the economic issues that we're
talking about are very serious and they
are very important from Dede who says
security risk tolerance and peace of
mind factored into investment decisions
and then asked rhetorically isn't that
one reason why the sector of retirement
savings I eat Social Security is best
left out of the market you know the the
proposal to put Social Security savings
in in the market that was that came out
more during that during the Bush
administration is it best I think you'll
have to see in 10 and 15 years whether
that was the best alternative to have
the federal government put it into these
special class of Treasuries
and essentially they're using all of our
contributions to fund the current
deficits when you look at the fourteen
point three trillion dollars of deficit
it did not include the unfunded
liabilities of the baby boomers hitting
the system so I think it's a very tough
area and I really encourage all your
viewers to pay very close attention wall
to step back a little bit from the
politics and start reading about the
about the issues they're incredibly
important to all of us I'm not sure
which would have turned out to be the
best one but we won't know for 15 or 20
years our last call is and joining us
from Ohio with patricia powell good
morning hi I wanted to ask Patricia I
mean the earlier D made some great
points about those who do not have any
extra capital to invest so I wondered it
Patricia
they talked about what percentage of the
American population has no extra capital
and then she responded by saying that we
all need to look at our spending habits
and that makes sense but a substantial
part of our national debt has to do with
an unnecessary war and the and the
revenues that were not raised to pay for
it but I also want to ask her if she
think that financial planning classes
should be taught like starting in the
freshman year of high school because a
lot of young people don't hear this
language at home and then I also wanted
to ask her if she knows that about this
2.5 trillion that a lot of the pundits
keep mentioning that the banks are
sitting on is that was that originally
money borrow from the taxpayers and does
she think rating agencies should be
rated by some other financial other you
know like Elizabeth Warren or somebody
like can we rate the financial rating
organizations and I gotta stop you there
we only have about 30 seconds left so
let me get a quick response from
Patricia Powell thank you for the call a
lot of questions there I'm actually
going to hone in on the the one that I
like the best and that is about should
finance of personal finance be taught in
high schools I would certainly love to
see something like that go on but
I want to be sure it's not at the
expense of kids learning math and
science and and reading because if you
if you have those skills you can learn
personal finance if you don't have those
skills you're not going to have much fun
in finance to manage if you want to get
more information you can log on to
Patricia Powell's website is pawel
Financial Group comm and one of the
points that you make more Americans
spend more time planning a vacation than
planning retirement
we're buying a toaster Patricia Powell
joining us from New York thanks very
much for being with us thanks for having
me